[Musik]
es ist das erste Wochenende an dem die
Clubs wieder öffnen dürfen in Italien
Schlange stehen vor der angesagten
römischen Location Orion rein darf nur
wer einen supergreenpass hat also
geimpft oder genesen ist heute Abend ist
für die ragazzi geöffnet Jugendliche
zwischen 15 und 20
alles okay
[Musik]
lassen werde ich sauer
endlich wieder feiern und das sogar ohne
Maske für manche vielleicht sogar das
erste Mal zwei Jahre waren die Clubs und
Diskotheken fast durchgehend geschlossen
jetzt läuft es wieder wenn auch viel
weniger rein dürfen als sonst
wir müssen die Sicherheit der
Jugendlichen gewährleisten also können
wir nur mit 50% der Kapazität operieren
und außerhalb der Tanzfläche muss eine
Schutzmaske getragen werden
[Musik]
oder an der Garderobe aber wir haben
geschafft zu überleben und sehen jetzt
Licht am Ende des Tunnels
die Mitarbeiter haben der
Wiedereröffnung dem ersten großen
Wochenende entgegengefiebert
Lichttechniker Livio gagliadi bis zum
letzten Moment an seiner super
lichtschau
bewegt und das funktioniert dann ganz
von alleine und dann haben wir Laser
dies und das sehen
er hat das alles vermisst die Atmosphäre
musikgäste und das Einkommen für seinen
Berufszweig waren staatliche Hilfen
dürftig
wenn man arbeitet wenn man nicht
arbeitet wird man depressiv und ohne
Geld um es kurz zu machen ist es ein
Problem für alle besonders wenn du
Familie hast diese zwei Jahre waren
schwer
sehr sehr schwer
die Öffnung der Diskotheken für geimpfte
ist dabei nur ein Schritt über 82% der
Gesamtbevölkerung sind zweifach geimpft
die Infektionszahlen sinken und Italiens
Regierung hat verfügt im Freien müssen
keine Masken mehr getragen werden
sondern nur noch in geschlossenen Räumen
wie etwa Geschäften
uns geht's besser wir atmen besser auch
wenn es die gleiche Luft ist die wir
durch die Masken einatmen
ich bin zweimal geimpft ich habe Corona
bekommen das war's fertig und nun fangen
wir an wieder einigermaßen normal zu
leben würde ich sagen jetzt ist es
endlich vorbei die Sonne scheint wieder
auf dem Markt
alle wollen die Masken abnehmen sie
fühlen sich mit ihnen sicherer
wir versuchen wieder zur Normalität
zurückzukehren aber das ist nicht so
einfach wie es scheint nach zwei Jahren
ist das hart wir sind alle ein wenig
misstrauisch gegenüber dem was vor oder
neben uns ist selbst wenn diese Pandemie
dass etwas neues kommt
Obsthändler Marco Faris dagegen ist
einer von denen die erleichtert sind
es ist eine schöne Sache Menschen ohne
Maske mit einem Lächeln zu sehen man
spricht besser man fühlt sich besser wie
früher wie vor ein paar Jahren
[Musik]
Strategie der italienischen Regierungen
steht hier im Gesundheitsministerium
Staatssekretär Pia Paolo silleri ist
Mediziner und hat sie maßgeblich
mitentwickelt in bereits zwei
Regierungen so hat Italien eine gut
organisierte Impfkampagne und ein
stringentes farbwarnsystem massive
Proteste sind ausgeblieben wohl weil die
Maßnahmen nachvollziehbar sind
sie dürfen dies nicht essen sie dürfen
das nicht essen sie dürfen sich nicht
körperlich betätigen nicht ins
Fitnessstudio nicht Autofahren natürlich
ist es schwer aber wir müssen es als
Mittel zur Behandlung akzeptieren
jetzt gleich da gleichzeitig hat man
Maßnahmen verschärft was ungeimpfte
angeht vor allem für über 50-Jährige
Version des screenpass der Impfpflicht
für über 50-Jährige haben wir genau den
Teil der Bevölkerung geschützt der im
Falle einer Infektion am in einem
Krankenhausaufenthalt benötigt auf der
Normalstation oder der Intensivstation
[Musik]
geändert es gibt fast immer
Präsenzunterricht Paola Senesi
Direktorin an der Giulio cesary Schule
in Rom kontrolliert wie viele ihrer
Klassen heute von corona-infektionen
betroffen sind
die corona-situation ist viel besser
viel besser
sehr viel einfacher wesentlich weniger
Fälle zum Glück wie viele Klassen sind
denn momentan im distanzunterricht keine
gibt es zwei oder mehr corona-fälle in
der Klasse bleiben die ungeimpften zu
Hause erst bei mehr als fünf Fällen muss
die gesamte Klasse in Quarantäne für die
Schülerinnen und Schüler ein Glück meint
die Direktorin es ist für Sie wichtig im
Präsenzunterricht zu lernen es ist etwas
anderes als wenn man zu Hause ist weit
weg auf Distanz zu den Mitarbeitern den
Lehrern zu uns allen die neuen Regeln
vereinfachen vieles unterlauben uns auch
dafür zu sorgen dass es möglichst keinen
distanzunterricht gibt da der sehr
anstrengend war
Martina de Angeles und ihre Freundinnen
haben zwei harte Jahre hinter sich in
denen sie sich oft nicht sehen konnten
oder in der Schule Angst hatten gleich
wieder in Quarantäne zu müssen wegen
eines positiv-falles in ihrer Klasse
termine bitte die figurdaten für mich
war die größte Schwierigkeit nicht zu
wissen was mich langfristig erwartet
[Musik]
was passiert jetzt denn es war immer
sehr ungewiss
jetzt fühlen wir uns eindeutig viel
gelassen
[Musik]
zwei Jahre lang haben sie hier in
Italien oft in der Ausnahmesituation
gelebt sich damit immer wieder
arrangiert jetzt kehren sie zu so etwas
wie Normalität zurück Schritt für
Schritt